so what I'm going to show you today is a
a game that I haven't seen in many
places I was very very happy to see that
not that many people still know about
this game I couldn't find it in my
database which is really nice i just
have it in an old book and the player
with the white piece is a master who is
not very well known is that his last
name is arnold and the player with the
black pieces a little more known he was
one of the best russian soviet players
at the time his time the beginning of
the that's at the end of the 19th
century and the beginning of the 20th
century his name is Mikhail chigorin
anybody ever heard of Chi Goren so he
heard of him very good very good does
that she go in defense and there's a
joke on variations made love to him yeah
so let's take a look what I'm hoping
that you will pick up from this game is
how to play very actively and how to
think a little bit like I always like to
say outside of the box we know the value
of the pieces we know what we want to do
in a chess game but sometimes we just
have not to be completely robotic we're
not Ottomans right we have our mind we
have creativity we have imagination we
don't want to play just like like
machines so let's take a look at the
opening and we have the two nights
defense right now I want somebody to
raise their hands and tell me what is
the most aggressive approach from
White's point of view to this variation
what is the most active dynamic wife
that white can play in this position
because we know why can play quiet move
so you can play like maybe d3 you know
sometimes can play d4 which is okay
active I guess somewhat but what is the
most aggressive approach you could tell
me addy Knight to g5 that is correct so
in the game that was no exception and
again we have to remember this is a very
old game and in this position some of
you might be in panic because oh my
goodness there's a very annoying fork
both the night in the bishop are
attacking the point
seven can we easily defend that porn no
the rocky and defended the bishop can
defendant the Queen doesn't want to
defend it is too expensive those guys
are vacationing right busy and nobody
can defend it so the only way if you
don't want to give up material by
playing Bishop c5 the only way to do it
is by playing the move d5 you have to
cut off the diagonal of the bishop with
the square and f7 the very weak square f
seven so now black is the one who's
attacking he is attacking the pawn on e4
twice but is night and form is attacking
the bishop even more importantly so the
normal reaction is pawn takes on d file
now many of you might already know but
for those of you who don't know it's
very dangerous to recaptured upon
normally when we give up upon we want to
just take back and you might say hey
Aviv why not I have a night attacking it
and my queen is protecting it white only
has a bishop defending it but here white
has so much development that can become
very dangerous if he is in the game he
moved his night and we'll talk about
that but if he was to take here yes that
is right this is a great opportunity to
sacrifice a piece now I don't want you
guys to go every game now giving up your
pieces like it's Christmas right we want
to think of the appropriate time to give
away your pieces so here we know we want
to do nine f7 how many know how many of
you know what what this is called
advanced approach a storage area that's
right he's a vegetarian and that's a him
to the name yes the fried liver attack
yes takes Queen after echeck forking the
king in the Queen and the king and the
Queen and the night the king in the
night so the King has to go up the board
how happy is this King to be here not
very happy after Knight c3 this is a
huge attack now you have to use this
night to defend the night like this and
this is very very dangerous for
you
so not a five so now the night is on the
rim attacking this Bishop so the bishop
gains a temper by playing Bishop to b5
check and now black plays am NOT a
strange move a move that's really hard
for us to understand but again this is
what I wanted to keep an open mind about
this class and about this opening this
opening is really really odd instead of
just playing let's say Bishop to d7
blocking the check normally he plays
pawn to c6 which means two things one
instead of regaining the upon that we
lost we're going to give up another
point so at the end of this sequence
much is going to be a perfon and our
pawn structure is going to be really
really funny cell of course white takes
the black part on c64 the bishop and the
pawn on d5 so he took and now we take
with the pawn of course we know we don't
want to take with the night if you take
with the night for example Bishop c4 you
remember that problem on f7 I we have it
again not so not so funny yeah so we
check with the pawn by taking with the
pawn of course the night on a five
doesn't let the bishop go back to see
for then hits them the point is hitting
the measure now you will notice how many
moves how many moves off tempo how much
gain of time black is going to get here
now there are many variations online to
talk about we only have limited time so
I'm going to go relatively fast but I
can tell you that in this position there
other moves Queen f3 is an interesting
move and Bishop d3 is an interesting
move but those are for another time so
in the game he went Bishop to e2
retreating and white said I had just
about enough of this night on g5
attacking me trying to hurt me so kick
back the night can go to h3 as well but
of course from h3 is really not going
anywhere so that's not the most popular
thing but it's still possible instead
Knight f3 one of the main lines hitting
the pawn on e5 so black says okay that
I'm going to hit you back the pawn
advances notice that white is really
dying to Castle and develop his pieces
but with every
there's a threat and he has to do
something about it so first of all his
bishop was hit that his night was hit
now again his night his head now denied
doesn't have that many moves I don't
think you want to go night two hear
after which g5 whoopsie what happened to
the night it's gone it's trapped yes so
how many of you want to go here where
the Queen can take it not many right and
nygean also very very unappetizing
doesn't look fun so he plays 95 even
here there are lots and lots of moves
black can play for example Queen to d4
Bishop c5 with all kinds of lives he
chooses to play Queen c7 one of the
possible moves developing the Queen and
already tickling the knight on d5 he
wants to take the night and that night
doesn't have that many good squares to
go to so he decides to go F for
defending the night now black continues
he goes developing his Bishop to d6
again hitting the night a second time
and white again responding with d4 so we
see that for the sacrifice porn blog got
a lot of time but it's still going to be
a lot of work trying to prove that we
have a reason to sacrifice upon right
now we have a funny night we have a
funny pawn structure right but we'll see
that this is you'll see how dangerous
this position can become ok so now black
castles finally he gives white the move
to do whatever he wants and white says
ok that is a good idea now the game
really really starts until now it was
developing sacrificing upon a little bit
of trick few tricks in the opening and
now I want some advice from you let's
pretend that you're black what move or
moves you have let's pretend that you
just got this position but you like it
or not that's what you have so what
would you do I want to hear candidate
moves what ideas might you have take a
look and thinking okay I'm down upon do
I really want to trade pieces do I
really want to play quietly passively or
do I want to get the initiative and try
to prove that I have something for my
pawn
I agree yes okay yes I like this move I
like this move as a [ __ ] this move
is coming very very shortly that's a
very smart move the look is very sleepy
in the corner and instead it takes the
semi open file the half-opened file yes
that's exactly what happened excellent
move that pawn was a very weak pawn very
annoying porn we don't like it there
what do we do we use it for the best
possible purpose we are attacking the
most important center square now I'm
positive that most of you can see that
the fear if white falls asleep here he
can be punished because black has a
threat he wants to take the port on d4
if Queen takes d4 Bishop c5 what a
beautiful skewer of the Queen right
that's going to be really really nice if
that happens so why it says now let me
defend my stuff then the pawn is
supporting the center and now indeed
comes the move rugby I'm not even gonna
bother to ask you because somebody
already said that that is a great move I
like moves like this it's activating the
rook that is active and the rook is
already looking at this pawn get this
Bishop easily move now no because he's
babysitting the pond now another good
reason for this move is that white got
an idea he said okay let's see what can
I do my queen said is undeveloped but i
can develop my rock it can't even move i
can develop my bishop i may lose by porn
so it's time to develop my night where
should I develop my knife I can either
develop it to where i block my beshert
or maybe i can go to a three-win it and
on a 3 i'm also going to be threatening
a beautiful for convey five can you
imagine this night wanting to go here
attacking the Queen and the bishop that
looks really lovely so he said okay 93
and now I'm threatening to go to be five
and this is why I'm showing you the game
because I want you guys to understand
that not every
under the threat we have to just respond
to it like a robot we can use our
imagination here black set a tiny little
trap and white was very very naive and
he fell right into it and let me show
you what I mean because it's not so
obvious here black simply played pawn
takes pawn that's a good move we already
know that Queen takes is out of the
question because of Bishop to c5 winning
it so he should just play pawn takes
pawn maybe he was worried after pawn
takes pawn that block will take the
night on a three and then those pawns
are really terrible and black has great
game but I think that he should have
done it he should have played see takes
d4 instead he said wait a minute I have
a bigger threat than my opponent I'm
going to threaten his Queen and he's
going to have no time to save his pawn
so let me play the move Knight to be
five that is a very very aggressive move
I'm attacking everything I'm attacking
the Queen I'm attacking the bishop I'm
attacking the porn on a 7 i'm attacking
the pawn on d4 and my bit my night is
protected by my bishop so now the
question is what did you how many of you
think we should just lose our queen I
knew it one person so yeah yes they
learn chess what can I tell you is not
here yet he doesn't really belong in
this class that's true so what should we
do what to do with a screen yes yeah
Queen to e7 moving the Queen away from
danger and still protecting the bishop
before it gets lost I agree any other
ideas how many of you are thinking about
27 here anybody else nobody else was
thinking about it okay but I saw other
hands up who wanted to say something
else yes you mean d8 right d 8 yeah the
same print the same thing again moving
the Queen to d8 moving the Queen away
and still protecting the bishop but I'm
sure that all of you can see that if the
Queen goes to d8 and I'm going to take
the bishop and you will take and then my
queen will take back the pond white is
up upon an end game and no Queens no
night for this very good bishop he's
black happy in that position he's down
upon plus he just traded lots of pieces
sometimes we have to just use our
imagination when I look at the cons in
the center the e4 and d 4 points I'm
saying wow those pawns are priceless
they are amazing i love those pawns and
i'm digging myself you know what I was
down upon and now I got it back so
material is even for now maybe it's time
for a little investment maybe i'm going
to give something and i'm going to get
lots of play for it and therefore he did
who wants to say you want to say Quincy
five of course is another option with a
queen no joy to safety and
uh-huh maybe but yeah exactly that's
also true Queen d8 is even maybe before
you're right but here in any event black
simply solve this problem in a very
smart way now when I show it to you I
don't want everybody to just go ahead
and do it if every one of your games it
really depends on the position here you
will see that it's a justified sacrifice
BAM rook takes Knight on b5 some of you
might say wait a minute wait a minute
the rook is worth five and the night is
worth 35 is bigger than three I don't
want to give my room for the night and
the answer is well sometimes you do in
this position you definitely want to do
that so of course you have to take back
and another very strong move by black
Queen to be 6 not only easy hitting the
bishop and is about to munch on it but
also he wants to do something with this
porn because this is a discovered attack
and you'll see that the queen is
opposite the King on the diagonal and
when I do something with the spawn is
going to become a check so very very
good now we can see that black is
getting a lot of a lot of stuff for that
exchange a lot of three moves a lot of
action okay why decided well what am I
going to do with my bishop if I move my
Bishop to e2 then after d3 Chuck and the
pot is going to take my bishop and he
wasn't happy about it so he decided to
play the move a for now black played a
decent move but I don't think it was the
best move I think the best move here
would have been to play 86 right here
right now then the game would transpose
it'll be exactly like what happened in
the game because in the game black
played something that was not accurate
and white plate something that was not
so accurate but the best move here is a
six in the game he went well what should
we do but we already know that a six is
the best move but if we ignore a six
what else do we have we want to do
something with this pawn on d4 we know
that if we do something with this porn
is going to be a check so whatever we do
with this pawn black is going to have to
respond why would have to respond to the
check so what do I want to do with this
pawn now this is again a tricky question
because the first thing we think about a
I can take something for free
I can take this pawn and he won't be
able to take me back he's going to have
to respond to the check but here we
don't want to do that because those
pawns together are so strong and you're
going to see it all the way to the end
of the game that there is no way that
I'm going to separate them I don't want
to just win upon I already gave up a
look for a night so watch what he does
he does check the King moves to the
corner and now a six so he basically
locks the boy back to the bishop and he
plays a six the problem is that now
black can sacrifice his bishop for those
two pawns and believe me that would have
been a very good deal that as good as it
gets this Bishop is so clumsy that he
should just have taken here and just
take him the second point and this is
why black should have first played a six
when that point was here before he
pushed up so that the bishop cannot
sacrifice its own then he would have to
play the move that he plays now which is
not the best move like because
sacrificing is the best the bishop
cannot move anywhere so he plays Knight
c4 in order to try to save his piece he
is moving his goodnight from me five now
that poor Knight is training for the
night on a five of course Black is not
set to trade this piece because this
piece is his worst piece and that was
why it's best piece so that's a very
pleasant trade of course we attack the
Queen in the night so he took it and he
took back very nice so we had a series
of very interesting moves and now the
big question is how to continue when we
count the material we see that black is
down a whole exchange a rook for a night
two points but if you ask me what color
I would want to be well guys it's a very
easy question I would much rather be
black all the black pieces are active my
king is much safer I have a beautiful
pawn duo on e4 and d3 now let's see who
can suggest the next move now usually
what happens in the class they suggest a
move and then we discuss it and then
they improve on it let's see what
happens in this class what should we
play
don't be afraid to be wrong try to look
at the position thing if I was black
what would I want to do here what will
be my choice yes blue shirt yes well you
got it right on the first try normally
everybody in every class wants to play
the move Knight g4 because how many of
you know what smothered mate is some of
you know okay let's let me show you the
demonstration for those who don't know
almost let's pretend Knight g4 and let's
pretend white place of funny move just
for the heck of it so we go check
double-check Queen sac mistake and may
this is smothered mate because the King
gets smothered in the corner so many
players when they see this position they
say hey Aviv nigera bout to do something
some damage and I say well then idea of
Nigeria is a fantastic idea but before I
go to 90 I want to improve the position
of all my pieces I don't want just my
night to participate I'm looking at this
guy on c8 isn't here sleepy bishop don't
we want to wake him up so yeah we want
to wake him up now how many of you
played bughouse how many of you play bag
us a lot of you ok very good let's
pretend that you got let's pretend that
this Bishop is out of the board hiding
you have it in your hand where would you
run it when you want to put it name a
square would you want to put it like if
you can use it right now what square on
the board with you I know where I want
to put it change very good guess but now
say it Bishop on e2 of course don't be
an awesome Bishop that isn't that a
beautiful place for the bishop oh yeah
who can argue with that now do you think
the computer is going to let me play it
if I did it let's start back house ok so
the second best thing is to do it in
stages step 1 attack the queen with a
bishop now if you don't do something
with the Queen bye-bye queen so here why
try to be smart but that didn't work out
too well he try to attack the black wii
as well and here black played the move
Queen a7 you just wanted to stay on the
diagonal and that wasn't so bad but he
could have done even worse if you were
to play Queen c5 attacking the bishop
staying on the diagonal and also the
Queen can shift to h5 that would have
been very annoying instead he played
here ok do you have a question it's some
people play like that but I think that
he replayed that you can do anything if
you put any peace even on the last ring
so except the font that's right so all
right so the Queen has to move now I'm
going to have you hey turn around please
now the Queen doesn't have that many
squares so it between two moves in the
game he played a very funny move a funny
move I was really surprised to see the
move let's see I'm gonna play it well
first I'll tell you what the best movies
then I'm going to play I want somebody
tell me why am i unhappy with this move
I think the move that should have been
played his Queen to e1 that's my move
but in the game he went why am i sad
about this move what do I why do you
think I'm criticizing in this move what
what don't look for moves I just want
you to be don't look for the next move
for black just try to tell me in words
what don't i like about this idea of
going tween a4 yes ok that's one thing
the queen is not super active there but
more to the point I want to hear
something very specific why is it Queen
better off on e 1 then it isn't a four
because where are things happening yeah
that's right the crewmen have been much
better off as a defender on me one that
it is going hunting something on a form
that is correct so now we know the
continuation of the plan Bishop to e2
awesome and rookie one trying to keep
the rook save now what to do I
definitely want to see more than two
hands up I want you guys to look at the
position concentrate think yourself what
can i play in this position what should
I play how can I continue my aggression
what how can I be active aggressive how
can i use my pieces that I'm not doing
something special right now how can I
use them to punish my opponent I'm
seeing only two people raising their
hands I want you guys to think about it
let's see okay let's talk about what
we're happy with and we definitely happy
with the king I'm not going to get my
king running around back right here and
we're not going to do that we're happy
with the pawns the pawns are exactly
where we wanted to be this Bishop is as
good as it gets on each you the queen is
doing a great job on the diagonal but
get the Queen by it self control do
everything no the Queen needs help we
have to keep this in mind we haven't
used a rock but where can we go if you
go here the Queen will take it here so
what so what so what so on nothing
exciting happening with this rope right
now this Bishop again I'm not exactly
sure what I want to do with it I can
take anything I can improve how about my
knife can I improve my night maybe I can
do something with my knife yeah what do
you think yes
now it's the lights turn to jump to g4
and we already know what the threat is
smothered mate Nige e49 h3 Queen g1 and
then night to f2 mate alright so black
says white says I need to have some
escape square for my king and he's
attacking that night he wants to take
that night off the board again black
played a very aggressive move here and
again it's kind of thinking ahead some
of you might say oh I can just give a
check with the night and then I'll say
okay my king goes here and then what of
course black still look great but so
what how do we get more space more
activity more threats against the poor
white king because if you look at the
king he looks super alone all those
other pieces the Queen and the bishop
and the bishops and the rook they are
somewhere where are they now somewhere
in the Bahamas right vacationing sailing
or something yeah very nice very smart
however we'll look for another move yes
93 is a possibility but I want to ask
you a question which piece is better the
bishop on see one that hasn't even moved
yet or my very active night on g4 even
though the boat were three I much prefer
the night right do I want to trade for
the bishop maybe not yet right I know
he's attacking but again like I always
tell my students in every class and
every lesson if you have a bigger threat
than your opponent don't respond to his
threat think do I have a bigger threat
can I create a bigger threat improve my
position and make a bigger threat than
just him taking my night if I have that
then who cares about the night yes
husband
of course Queen F to the Queen goes
right into the thick of things attacking
the rook on e 1 beautiful just beautiful
what a great position well what to do
now it's really miserable it really is
sad you can even sacrifice because in
the game he played here but I think that
if you would have taken here then I
would have played like check check check
the double good what happens after
Bishop e3 the White King doesn't look
happy does it No so back we go Bishop TD
cheer now again there are many many
winning moves believe me there's more
than one where you move let's hear if
you can suggest some of them pretend
that you're black all your pieces are
working together except for maybe one or
two but ok the rukon f8 is protecting
the King a little bit so that's not bad
plus you have enough stuff you really
really have a lot of stuff so only one
person can find me a move here I want
everybody to concentrate everybody to
take a good look pretend that you use
your imagination don't be afraid to play
an aggressive move look at the Queen the
night in the bishop maybe you don't need
all of them for the attack maybe you can
use some of them
yes to hear hear and what if the pond
takes yeah we if we can sack the Queen
it could be nice but maybe not just yet
to hear okay so Queen here and you're
threatening checkmate right yeah wait a
minute who with just how does it go one
movies right whose move is it now well
let's see what if I take this knife wait
a minute don't don't despair yet don't
take a good look at the position take a
good look in position what can you do to
me you can check me and that'll be my
only legal move and you can check me
look at this and I only legal move and
then you'll take it and yeah so even
this works yeah another good alternative
yeah yeah I mean pony 3 i'm sure it's
winning material yeah it's a disaster
right completely disaster Bobby the best
move maybe bishop f3 also looking really
great if pawn takes bishop then Queen
here is made otherwise with threatening
made here and the Queen g3 it's just the
end of the world he decided to play the
move Bishop to c5 also looking very very
nice that's the different move order now
again he wants to play Queen g3 with
mate and if you take the night it's made
look at this night cream Bishop Bishop
wow so many pieces around the king how
many defenders of this King not too many
not good news so white is already lost
when he's desperate he's trying to play
a last trick Bishop takes pawn
what else is about to get made it so he
tries to sacrifice his bishop and in
this position white played a move that I
was really really surprised by I think
that he play I'm guessing that he played
this move only because maybe he saw what
happened in the game and he planned for
that but i think that that was very very
unwise what would you play in this
position let's pretend that you're black
you're about to make your opponent your
brother just play Bishop takes pawn
check we know that he's trying to get
the screen into the thick of things what
should we do Adi that's what I would
have played King h8 okay so you took my
pawn so what what's next for you nothing
right he's in trouble but she gone and
he was a grand master level player he
decided to take this very confusing
really really confusing I cannot
understand why he did that well he's
still winning obviously the only reason
you'll see is probably what happened in
the game so check why even allowed this
sháá King here and now yeah maybe you
should have played the Queen takes pawn
check but then after g6 he doesn't have
any more checks black he's still winning
but why even get to this position but he
just took the rock this is what the
answer our friend yeah so Sarah says
died on the full stomach you're about to
get made it so at least you get to eat
whatever you have a chance to eat now
who could tell me what black played in
this position black played something
very very good I was very impressed I
have to say that when i saw this game
and i went over this part relatively
fast i was like well what's that and
then when you look at it it's like wow
yeah I got your hands very good yes I'm
positive that this is an interesting
move but the remember before the blacky
was safe and now white is threatening
all kinds of unknowing checks here check
and more check it could be a perpetual
check so this is why it's easy to get
because any move that you play here that
allows me to check you and I might just
escape so think of the plan or the move
that doesn't allow me to do that yes yes
wait let's take a look let's go slow he
sacks the screen on g2 what a beautiful
clean queen sacrifice just for one point
well I know what I have to do I have to
take it Bishop after we check and you
have to legal moves but they both get
made it in the game he played here and
bam checkmate two bishops of the night
made the king even without the queen
beautiful instead if you would have
played the King to g3 who can tell me
what would have been the beautiful
finish yes correct the bishop would have
done at this time f3 and then Bishop
after yes and mate a beautiful beautiful
finish excellent this is one position I
always like to do one game one position
and some one other thing so let's take a
look at this end game we look at this
position and we know you guys don't
really play many end games I know that
but this is just a very nice idea in an
endgame something that's really really
worth knowing in this position we can
see that each side has a night and each
side has six spawns and right now the
black position looks really good he has
a beautiful chain of pawn chain of ponds
here and white is kind of funny for
double pawns and all that the nighttime
d1 looks like a real terrible piece how
many moves can I make with this night
without losing it zero is correct if I
go here I lose it if I go here I lose it
in the meantime the Black Knight is
attacked by the White King and where is
it going to go can go here it can go
here it can go here it can go here it
looks like it did so much trouble maybe
has to go back yeah so let's pretend
that we are black in this position what
should we play use your imagination in
this position think yourself if I said
black to move and win then you will know
oh wow that has to be a really serious
move here because if we were to win and
ask yourself win win how is there going
to be a checkmate here do you think the
night is going to make the right thing
that has like ten legal moves now so we
have to think how are we going to win
who could tell me in words without even
seeing the moves without even seeing the
plans use your imagination if black is
going to win how is he going to win
either he's going to win material or
what else yes red shirt yes you yes
well I mean you could check the king but
then the question is what's going to
happen with the night after check in the
King goes to eat you I'm attacking you
night and probably unites us to hide all
the way here right I'm not sure about
that besides he has a very good
continuation but first answer my
question one of you answer my question
how are you going to win it's not going
to be my checkmate right now so what's
going to happen tell me you want to get
one of your pawns to wear to the
queening square you want to Queen one of
your point if one of your pawns make it
to the last rank you're going to be
making the Queen right now it's not easy
i promise you if you push the pawns it's
not going to work right now but black
used all of his imagination and he
managed to create exactly that Knight to
c3 what a surprising move some of you
might say I see the faces of somebody
like Aviv are you feeling well you just
give up a night for a porn what but yes
I'm feeling perfectly fine the point is
like that first of all my throat is to
take your night that can't move and
can't be defended that's 12 if you take
with the night and I take with the pawn
I'm attacking your porn when the pawn
takes my phone is just going to run all
the way to the Queen Square and that
also what happened in the game in the
game he played pong tanks he tried it
and a for who is going to stop the a
pond I don't know it's going to be very
tough very tough you cannot stop it so
he played pawn takes here now he's
really hoping that if the pawn starts
running tooth too soon then the night is
going to come here and catch it but
black simply took back and he said no no
night you're not coming here and now
there is no hope you can try this move
what else if you take here I take back
and the pawn just marches him can't stop
it so he tried to move c3 again he is
hoping maybe the pawn is going to take
on c3 or maybe the phone is going to
take on b3 and then the night is just
going to be on time to stop it but
blacks
said listen I have only one idea I want
a new queen and he played a three cat
this pawn be stopped nope and therefore
what did why do he resigned yeah he said
I don't want to play down the Queen
against my night so he resign
you